[Laughter]
huh huh
[Laughter]
[Music]
[Music]
an executive producer of the
nationally syndicated radio and tv
program that the david hackman
[Music]
david
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
can you remind the audience
[Music]
[Applause]
uh
[Music]
is
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
is
[Music]
look at that look at that
work it down look at that
look at that look at that that
is smarter than you why who thinks he's
smarter than you smarter
[Music]
is
[Music]
that might come as a shot
[Music]
[Music]
jones has fake callers jones has fake
claws
[Music]
tyranny
[Music]
[Music]
elements of bathrooms
we're looking very strongly in sinks and
showers
[Music]
elements of bathrooms
what on earth is going on with trump and
toilets
trump's white house toilet
would be clogged
clogged
[Music]
with documents that donald trump was
flushing down sure
is this the explanation is this the
explanation
the big massive dump obama
[Music]
[Music]
god bless
the united states thank you very much
elements of bathrooms well welcome
everybody we are really in the thick and
the wide of the 2022
midterms tonight we have a very
important debate in what is the race
that quite frankly oh i'm muted oh god
oh not again
oh no
not this again
dear god
these people don't know what the hell
they're doing
no i'm kidding i know i'm not muted for
once i actually have somewhat of a grasp
on what's going on technically um this
this uh quite frankly this race could
decide whether democrats or republicans
control the senate in 2023
um the this is the pennsylvania senate
tonight on newsmax they will have the
republicans debate and that includes
mehmet oz
that includes dave mccormick and the
three other people whose names i really
really struggle to remember and that's
okay we're gonna find out what their
names are we've got about a half hour
till it starts and i have so many things
to talk about with you guys so i am
truly truly truly glad that you're here
uh where to begin well
let me start with some thank yous i want
to say thanks to
the infamous small fuzzy moss
arguably the best moderator we have
except every other moderator disagrees
green man
and symbolic gamer for the twitch prime
subscriptions very much appreciate that
and yes the coupon code obama obama is
live today now who has dr uh i'm sorry
who has donald trump endorsed tonight
uh it's not even clear he knows we've
endorsed jp right j.d mandel
okay he has he's endorsed dr us that's
who he has actually endorsed and uh that
one he he seems to have some somewhat of
a sense of so that's who is trump's pick
at trump so far getting a win in that
jd vance who is actually the person that
he endorsed
won last night in ohio
nina turner lost i believe j.r majewski
or is it now i'm is it jp or j.r
majewski
j.r majewski
i interviewed him yeah he's also the
winner
i interviewed him and he was endorsed by
scrumps as well
so um so far trump is uh like two for
two
um i thought david was gonna stop
calling him doctor you know the tough
thing about that jp i'm sorry uh
symbolic gamer
is that not everybody knows who i'm
talking about if i only say mem at oz so
i'm sort of trying to
it's a tough thing it's a tough thing
but we're doing absolutely the best we
can with it thanks to h rochester
jen here and nick levin for the twitch
prime subscriptions really appreciate
that
also want to say a big thank you to
kevin gouldy who has just gifted a
subscription on my website that's number
seven
and that subscription goes to billy
boyle billy boyle some know him as jp
but i know him as billy
uh if you want a free membership it's
davidpakman.com
free membership that don't email me just
go to that website that's the place to
do it
okay let's get into some material here
where to start oh okay this is
interesting this is dave rubin's big
brain take on
the roe v wade decision listen to this
see if you can spot the problems the key
part of all of this uh it says and to
ensure that our decision is not
misunderstood or mischaracterized we
emphasize that our decision concerns the
constitutional right to abortion and no
other right nothing in this opinion
should be understood to cast doubt on
precedents that do not concern abortion
in other words if another case makes it
up to the supreme court they can't look
at this case and say this has anything
to do with say gay marriage or civil
rights or anything else so there's no
well ben shapiro disagrees
dave's good friend dave ben shapiro with
whom
ben shapiro may think that dave is
living in sin
and going to hell but they that's just
they're just friends you know
ben shapiro actually thinks
obergefell ha is it over the obergefell
case which legalized gay marriage that
that was also wrongly decided so it
actually may be next reason to believe
that suddenly they're going to be coming
for civil rights that suddenly uh you're
going to have laws oh they're literally
saying it
charlie kirk said today if we can if we
can overturn roe v wade
anything is possible does that stop
black people from doing something or
from gay people from doing something or
anything else now i can see already
what's going to happen here that there's
going to be all these people screaming
about gay marriage so let me just say a
couple things about the gay marriage
thing first off if you remember before
uh june of 2015 when the supreme court
decided the gay marriage case um it was
happening across the states can you can
we check on that how many states had gay
marriage passed already by the time the
supreme court did it i think it was 20
something states remember if you
remember that year there were states
that were just going ahead and doing it
properly state by state by state and
then the supreme court got involved and
said it is a federal right now the
difference
is that in the supreme court's decision
on gay marriage they talked about
specific clauses in the constitution
that were the basis for the law they did
in roe v wade as well not everybody
agrees with it but they talked about
that in roe v wade as well which roe v
wade did not have that's untrue roe v
wade just said hey it's a constitutional
right to have no wrote no roe v wade
also was based on um
was it correct me wasn't it right to
privacy based on the 14th amendment can
people in the chat fact check me
he may disagree that it was correct to
do that but it was also based on on the
constitution
people are saying yes
it come on guys i mean this is very low
low quality uh it's a very low quality
take
i would have expected marginally better
from dave rubin so anyway that's dave
rubin's big brain take based on uh
something that is wrong that he just
it's just wrong it doesn't make any
sense
um i want to say thank you to tommy
horswill
for
uh gifting a membership on my website
you're number eight and that membership
goes to
nancy harn nancy harn
thanks also to jay tandaway alice
maravius slingblade for the twitch prime
subscriptions putting us at 11.
should we continue with content do we
want to do content today
i know it's copium for me to say
actually
actually
it was based on the constitution all
right let's continue
here's a couple on a flight that were
using
homophobic slurs and then the woman
starts praising elon musk this is pretty
weaponized stuff
okay
we all know that being able to make it
through a domestic flight
is based on debating the first amendment
with flight attendants we know that
we're not coming off
and you're gonna have to take everyone
off
this is ridiculous
you guys see what's happening in america
you didn't like what he said and now
we're getting kicked off the plane and
all of you all are gonna we're getting
kicked off
all of you are responsible
this is [ __ ]
outrageous you guys
we're gonna turn into china
it's coming
oh
[Music]
you know what it's a beautiful day i'm
happy to say one more night
i am suing you what is your name oh when
they start with the lawsuits do you
think any of these people that claim
they're about to sue people are ever
really sue anybody do they do do they
even know who to call
sir
sue the people in row 24. uh ma'am i'm
an accountant buddy i got you everybody
in the airline oh my god
i have nothing
all right very very sick woman so we got
that
here's elijah schaefer
who is telling native americans to get
out of america that's weird
yeah native americans get the [ __ ] out
of america you're on stolen land that
you stole and you want to know why
manifest destiny happened you don't know
why we took it back because we couldn't
live with you on the land because you
guys kept declaring war on us and kept
declaring war and trying to take back
land that we already traded and or
bought from you and you did not
understand property rights because you
were savages and that's why you got the
name that you did
oh oh oh my
god oh my god that's
that's not even worth guys let's not
even
let's not even let's let's just not even
i think we're just gonna not even
here is uh don jr
he has an idea
go and buy
trump gold card
yeah donald trump jr here i'm reaching
out today because we're about to
finalize our trump gold card membership
roster and i wanted to give you one last
chance this is the last chance guys the
the rolls of the trump gold card are
almost full
they have almost no slots remaining
and this is the absolute this is a take
it or leave it guys
you even you either get the gold card or
you don't be a part of history with us
gold card members are made up of my
father's most reliable supporters right
and i know he'll be disappointed if
you're not on the team yeah
when you join we'll even send you a
personalized trump gold card right it'll
drive the limbs crazy yeah yeah
you know one of the things that really
fires me up it's not when abortion
rights are ended
when i see these trumpists enjoying
their trump gold card i just get
triggered as one of the libs i can't
take it please activate your membership
today before it's too late oof i can't
even watch it
it's too triggering for me that
trumpists might get a gold card
um
here's candice taylor she's running in
georgia
um
i guess she's running on ending a
satanic regime um this isn't just
actually
i'm gonna i i should even talk about
this this is this is crazy enough that i
should talk about it on the podcast
this one's wild look at this that's what
they wanted to do
some might even say
they had to get our permission
to at least tell us ahead of time
even if we didn't believe them
over four billion people have been
injected
with something that took just nine
months to create
ask yourself why
by the way i want to take this as an
opportunity to clarify something
the other day when we were reviewing
this woman's debate
she pronounced the word that it's known
to me
as children
children
and i said i don't know if that's a
georgia accent
or an educational thing and a bunch of
people wrote to me and said david you
shouldn't make fun of accents of
regional accents accents aren't an
educational thing
that i wasn't what what i was saying was
i don't want to make fun of an accent
what i'm saying is i don't know if
children
is just the way they say children in
georgia
in which case
fine that's just a regional accent
or if it's something about this woman
having some kind of weaponized speech i
i wasn't making fun of i wanted to make
sure i wasn't making fun of the accent
and people wrote to me and they were
like david that's not okay
back in biblical times human sacrifice
was a form of demonic worship
we're still doing it
in present day by killing our own born
it's the same demons it's the same
sacrifice it's the same sin
it's just a different time
this is a long shot in and of itself
running for governor against an
incumbent
why are you doing this
if we don't call things out and we don't
acknowledge them and we don't take
authority
and take dominion over what god's given
us the word dominion even is a is a dog
whistle to a certain uh
strand of christianity this has a cue
vibe to it
then
we are no better than the evil ones that
put it up
we've watched as people have destroyed
our history and monuments and in their
place they have erected statutes to
their own gods
[Music]
the new world order anyway you got is
here new world order yeah so this is
pretty standard stuff unfortunately like
unfortunately we're very familiar with
that kind of nonsense uh here's bill
barr saying that the leaker of the
supreme court opinion might have
committed criminal obstruction of
justice now that's not true what about
this martial investigation i mean i i'm
having covered the high court for a few
years i can say
the the supreme court marshal
investigating you isn't the sentence
that strikes fear in the hearts of men
and women
now the fbi
because cbs is reporting that there may
be an fbi investigation into who leaked
this that's a different story that's
more your purview so what do you think
happens from here who actually will take
the helm
well you know i think that the chief
would have had the option and perhaps he
still will to appoint a council uh
a special counsel we need a special
counsel over the decision being leaked
three weeks early
i actually think we need 12
congressional hearings too classical
criminal sense but the court can appoint
a counsel and he could bring in a former
u.s attorney or someone with a criminal
law background
and i'm sure he would get the support he
needed from the fbi or any other law
enforcement agency what's your
confidence that they can get to the
bottom of who leaked it
i think they may need a grand jury could
we get to the bottom of like taking
rights away from women that i'm more
concerned about that that which would
mean a criminal case wow why
to compel the truth yeah because people
will lie to the marshal
and maybe not to a prosecutor
perhaps
well that's the thing and
people are talking about it online
though is this a crime to me it's
clearly unethical and if it was a lawyer
they should be disbarred immediately
right but
what crime could this possibly be it
could be obstructing the the
administration of justice the due
process of justice yeah i've not seen
anyone else make that claim also what's
with this delivery it seems very
affected this kind of whisper
this
oh dude
get vaccinated yeah
it's kind of a whole thing bar seems
disoriented to be perfectly frank
uh here's dave you know what i'm going
to skip reuben actually
here's stephen crowder complaining that
only unattractive women complain about
abortion now well especially the first
one it's like what you worry about
guys
you were waiting like you're not worried
about that no
well that's what i have a theory it's
always really really unattractive women
who for example they [ __ ] about cat
calling they [ __ ] about abortion here's
the thing i know there are plenty of
attractive women who uh who believe in
the right to abortion that being said
women who are attracted this is just a
theory just to be clear this is it's
actually not a theory but okay it's it's
more of a hypothesis
just
this is just conjecture okay
i'm not a doctor on ugly chicks no
they
they look like because attractive women
who support abortion they still you know
they're often because they can have they
can sleep with whoever they want well
yeah they're interested in the the
choice but they're predominantly
concerned with usually attract women
like hey i'm not a [ __ ] you know what i
mean that's like hey i'm not a [ __ ] so
they typically don't want to go out and
shout their abortion these often women
want to be like look so everybody wants
to can't call me and i'm having so much
sex that i have to have all these
abortion you guys everyone's like
sure ooh this is an illness
this these these people they're very
very sick
um l diner production says via a very
powerful super chat so if they vote to
overturn i think my mic's about to
collapse
if they vote to overturn roe v wade
can't biden be a stop gap not in any way
that i'm aware of
jack says david did you hear dinesh
d'souza will be speaking at the trump
rally friday he's going to promote his
film 2000 mules i may have to cover that
we'll have to see i may have to cover
that
a couple other things here
here's candace owens um talking about
the freaks predators and pedophiles who
hide under the lgbt flag right i mean
i'm a big believer and i've said it once
i'll say it again that there are freaks
predators and pedophiles that are all
hiding under the lgbt flag right they're
waving the flag and going oh we're this
queer or whatever but you know uh and in
reality this is a perfect place if you
are a child predator for you to hide and
what better place than it's kind of not
because republicans for decades have
been claiming that gay people are
pedophiles so it's actually an
incredibly stupid place to hide that's
that's where every republican is looking
because that's what they think
uh
it's uh it it is really something else
um
okay so that's very dumb
bennett walker asks is it possible the
leak was intentionally done by a
republican to generate a distraction
story
anything is possible
but we i we just don't know and it's all
speculation right now so i can't say
anything more and then lastly here's
greg kelly from newsmax saying systemic
racism doesn't exist because there are
interracial marriages and oh by the way
i think this is interesting i also think
it's great they're all three of them are
in great committed relationships and
love is love and it's beautiful that
they found partners i don't care what
race they are but i am going to point
out that jonathan capart happens to be
uh with a white man and that's uh that's
wonderful but it does undermine the
whole idea that this is a systemically
racist country with white supremacists
everywhere same goes for maya wiley her
husband is uh not black and kimberly
atkins store
same goes for her
and uh oh by the way the two most
prominent black women in the country are
married to white men uh katanji brown
jackson didn't hear much about that by
the way and uh who's that the second
gentleman doug doug uh element somebody
like that emhoff is a cop yeah that's uh
that's doug element homeless husband
that's great again love is love i don't
but it does undermine that whole notion
the fact that five women
are married to white men tells us
anything about the country that's very
weird very very weird looks like we're
getting set up for the debate here
you've got the four candidates as well
as the moderator i'm sorry five
candidates and the moderator
greta van susteren that will be starting
soon very very soon i want to say thank
you to jake sorenson who just gifted a
subscription on my website and his new
member number 12. that subscription goes
to eric lane
also big thank you to cradler and bert
crudler and bert for the twitch prime
subscriptions uh so glad to see
everybody here our coverage of the 2022
midterm elections is really ramping up
at this point in time
multiple streams a week i would love for
you to support the 2022 work we are
doing the best way
the easiest way to do it and we will ban
men
no no we're no we're not banning anybody
no just get a membership on my website
okay you can sign up at
joinpackman.com you can use the code
obama as you can see here
and that gives you
a beautiful discount you can also do it
monthly and we keep all but 2.9 percent
of every dollar youtube doesn't allow
that tv doesn't allow that facebook no
way in hell they allow that and if you
have your own membership you can check
this box
and then we have 700 people who would
love a free membership you can gift one
very easy very very easy to do
and i will thank every
single person who signs up today
do i have any voicemails let's do one
whitney voicemail
so i was listening to amber hurt's
message or her testimonial about johnny
depp about how he hit her because he was
like super unclear
or he she was super unclear about like
his tattoos and stuff like that but you
see how like wound up people are about
like their bodies like when it's like oh
i don't really know what's going on with
your body and then
man i just i just don't know what she's
talking about
what if the leak came from one of the
five to make sure we get out the rage
energy early to burn out for november
anything's possible haley
i love that both trump and biden add the
letter n to words beginning with o obama
and omnicron nicely done
the leak came from the same blm and
antifa members who stormed the capital
on january 6th exactly
david when will there be warm food
i don't expect any i think the debate is
going to be uh start to finish start to
finish a welcome to beezus bp and our
friend deeper shades of house re-upping
twitch prime subscriptions really
appreciate that as you can see in the
polling it is tight between the top
three but memit oz a quack tv doctor
is
in the lead i want to say thanks to
saeed
al-mohanadi i hope i pronounced that
correctly as well as emilia romero for
the website subscription signing up at
joinpacman.com appreciate you very much
very very very much
um
okay wait oh real quick so this this
happened i was on the right wing show
trigger nomitry
as expected
their viewers
are very upset with me typical leftist
who mischaracterizes the right
you gave pacman way too much room on
trans
um
this guy is a smug [ __ ] anyway it would
be great if we brigaded this video
and just left beautiful positive
comments about my appearance only
because
obviously they would never expect that
let's let's look at a little bit of this
uh let's look at uh i don't know
let's start here and look at this topic
well uh before i come to the cultural
stuff and maybe the immigration point
you make as well you mentioned that you
thought that joe biden was the better
option at the last election yeah
what have you liked about uh the biden
administration and are you still of the
view that that was the right choice in
terms of voting for biden the two
from the two options it was the right
choice i mean to to speak candidly with
you gentlemen
donald trump was a humiliating
embarrassment i mean just the
the promises he made
none of them were kept you know he was
going to build a wall he didn't build it
he was going to
solve the israeli-palestinian conflict
jared actually was going to solve it his
son-in-law as you know it hasn't been
solved he was i mean there was a look
there was a lot of progress on that
would you concede that
i don't well what progress was there
well the israeli foreign minister
turning up in saudi arabia i mean all of
that stuff and better relations between
the countries in the region did you not
feel that that was some progress what
changed materially though
uh
look but maybe let's not spend too much
time on it so you did anything
let me put it this way did anything
change materially
i think it's quite a difficult situation
to change materially in the course of a
four-year presidency but so it didn't
that's fair okay we agree it didn't
change materially they did do some
optics things you know there was a
flight like from tel aviv to uae but i
think we're on the same page we can't
neither one of us can identify anything
that changed materially is that fair
um i i what i would say is i think some
progress was made in a very difficult
situation i don't claim that okay anyway
so that was one topic there was another
point where we talked about trans let me
see here
uh
let's listen to a let's see make sure
we're not missing anything okay
my issue is that in you know what let's
actually let's get back to this after
the debate because that i would love it
for people to just brigade with comments
during them i'll relate to them as a
woman
and we'll look at some of the comments
you guys leave oh wow a bunch of
comments have already been added very
intelligent and well-spoken man uv
lightning beautifully done beautifully
done uv this guy is absolutely inspired
awesome points from oh god they're this
is the best wow david pakman is so
handsome all right i mean i'll take that
wow pacman's really smart really makes
you think huh hey you know what also
would be funny for people to go
i used to be a trumpist and i now
realize the error of my ways david
pakman has converted and deprogrammed me
anyway
everybody
do that
during the debate and we'll go back to
this after because i don't i don't want
to miss any that's trigonometry is the
name of it okay trigonometry i want to
say thanks to philip nolan
for the website membership phillip just
signed up on my website thank you so
much also thanks to rachel klein
and ali prugar who just gifted
subscriptions on my website those are
numbers 20 and 21. those go to erica and
mark
erica oh hold on erica burke and mark
valentine get free memberships
free
lastly thanks to bone master jay bone
master jay
for the twitch prime subscription really
appreciate that the debate starts any
minute it is one hour then we will get
back to the trigger nomentry interview
uh oh thanks to alex jarvis as well
really appreciate everybody signing up
that we're just kind of streaming on a
whim but it seems that the 2022 stuff is
interesting to people
um
the channel is
trigonometry in fact i can just post the
link to this let me post it a couple of
times
on uh
youtube
and i'll post it a couple times on
tv
as we stand by for the debate
okay good all right yeah the debate the
debate is about to start so we're not
gonna miss it everybody relax
thanks to stephanie cripps
for gifting a membership on my website
that one goes to
carson meyer we just go in order
if you s if you ask for a free
membership more than once all the
requests get deleted and you get nothing
okay we're not we have 672 people
waiting for memberships
we're deleting duplicates you get
nothing that's just not the way the
system's supposed to work okay it's in
order
it's just an order man everybody wants
to game every system
um don't don't just don't even bother
you will get nothing
nothing
uh okay let's listen a little bit take
the lead of course this is what this
race is right i mean i just i think a
lot of people think oh well the guy
that's got the trump endorsement you
know is he's already in the lead
i couldn't possibly care less about
their analysis i just want to see the
debate uh and we will be we will be
seeing that
at any moment thanks to stur man ha for
the twitch prime subscription very much
appreciate that
um
what can you do if you're already a
member yeah we you can gift now we have
this box is this a gift
if you don't have anyone to gift a
membership to i've got
672 people waiting okay they want okay
here we go
vote for america 2022
a special newsmax debate the
pennsylvania primary for u.s senate
live from kentler auditorium at grove
city college your moderator greta van
susteren
[Music]
good evening
and welcome to grove city college in
grove city pennsylvania tonight we have
the top five republican candidates for
u.s senate trying to gain the support of
voters in this state the primary is may
17th before we get started a welcome
message from the grove city college
president right good evening i'm paul
mcnulty president of grove city college
we're delighted to welcome you to our
beautiful campus in western pennsylvania
for this important political debate more
importantly thanks to rachel klein for
gifting another membership rachel's
absolutely crushing it and i'm able to
give that membership to sebastian
thorson
very very much appreciate you
we're committed to academic excellence
and affordability in our learning and
living experience
faithfulness to our 1876 founding
purpose is one of our
people are asking is this going to be a
cringe stream yes
yes this is going to be a cringe stream
that's for sure
elections are the cornerstone of
representative democracy and the college
is honored to provide a forum for the
thoughtful exchange of ideas at
tonight's debate
we hope you find tonight's debate a
helpful and i have no idea if this is a
real college i've never heard of it that
doesn't mean anything i do i don't know
if it's a real college
and here are the candidates from left to
right ms kathy barnett
right
doctor
oz
i don't know about including doctor
ambassador carla sands ambassador
mr
dave mccormick
and mr jeff bartos
now the candidates positions on stage
were determined by a random drawing
prior to the debate all campaigns have
agreed to the debate rules we have
divided the questions and topics to
ensure the candidates have equal time
not all candidates will answer every
question answers will be limited to one
minute or less rebuttals to attacks will
be permitted if warranted
also asking questions tonight
pittsburgh's kdka radio anchor rick
dayton he's in the audience
candidates we have examined the polls
about issues of greatest concern to
voters both why did she say candidates
to better understand your proposed
policies we have looked at the
information on your websites statements
you've made your campaign ads and the
previous debate in which all of you
participated
now we know that during the last debate
you spent a good deal of time on your
pennsylvania roots so we believe this
topic has been covered some questions
will be given to all candidates others
will be directed to certain candidates
all candidates will have equal amounts
of time so here's the first question
this is for all of you everyone is
talking about the leaked supreme court
draft this decision could overturn roe
versus wade you have also how many times
would you kill the leaker in favor of
any exceptions for abortions have you
changed your opinion over the years if
so what has changed your mind you have
one minute miss barnett you're first
thank you
uh whether this was a leak or whether it
was a tactical operation we will soon
figure out but one thing is clear i am
so very grateful that our nation is now
having a very important conversation and
that is one of the most important
conversation that is about life
i am the byproduct of a rape my mother
was 11 years old when i was conceived my
father was 21. i was not just a lump of
sales as you can see i'm still not just
a lump of cells my life has value and
that is one of the reasons why it was so
very disturbing when i saw mehmet oz
running for this particular race when
i've seen him on numerous occasions and
specifically at the breakfast club
saying that my life was nothing more
than a uh acorn with electrical currents
i am wondering if the good doctor has
now since changed his position on that
my life is valuable and so are the so
are the many lives that find themselves
in the womb of their mother whether in
the womb or towards the end of that life
dr oz you have 30 seconds to respond
that was directed at you sir
you know one of the toughest
endorsements you can ever get is from
your mother-in-law and my mother-in-law
is an ordained minister she wrote a lot
of the pro-life literature in montgomery
county where we live and she certainly
understands that i'm pro-life as a heart
surgeon i've operated on small children
a few days old and witnessed the majesty
of their hearts pounding blood even
though it's ill because i'm operating on
them
through those bodies i would never think
of harming that child or even nine
months earlier because life starts at
conception all right mr bartos now your
one minute answer to the question i'm
pro-life and pennsylvania has a proud
tradition
of sending united states senators to
washington who are pro-life from both
parties we have a tradition of sending
governors to harrisburg from both
parties this is the guy who in the last
debate was just so boring he was painful
to listen to is too important to trust
from two people who are from connecticut
and new jersey i assure you connecticut
and new jersey do not have proud
traditions of sending senators to
washington and governors to their state
capitals who are proudly pro-life
dr oz now your one-minute response to
the question i can finish
sorry
i still have time right
you and your one minute that was one
minute yeah i'll yield my one minute to
jeff bartos i think i asked you a
question adequately okay i'll give you
30 seconds mr pardus john fetterman has
said with absolute clarity
that he is going to washington to make
abortion legal on demand anytime
anyplace he is called abortion sacred i
will beat john fetterman in november and
i will proudly take our pennsylvania
main street pro-life values to
washington i only had 42 seconds there
mr mccormack
well this uh this leak memo if it
becomes the court's decision is a huge
victory for the protection of instant
life it's a huge step forward and it
also pushes the decisions
down to the state level and voters where
they should be so
we'll see if it becomes if it becomes a
ruling if it does i would embrace it and
i would be very very happy about it but
i want to go back to memit because i
think that's not an adequate answer if
you go back to that breakfast club
interview
uh which was three years ago this month
he talks about a whole different set of
positions the attacks the pro-life for
uh picking fights he attacks states that
put in pro-life legislation is
disrupting business and this is
something that understand mccormick is
the one who has the bet most to gain by
directly attacking memit because
mccormick's in second place right now
behind memit another example of you
being phony in terms of the positions
you're putting forward ambassador sands
before i get to my answer i just want to
thank newsmax for hosting this debate i
want to thank you
and i also want to thank the gentlemen
on either side of me for showing up
because they don't come to many of our
debates as a matter of fact one is uh dr
oz and i think it's probably because
he's what i call a minnow and that's
magga in name only minnow whoa he's
afraid and then we have
romney mccormick next to me because when
he's in the senate he would vote like
mitt romney and uh and we know what that
means but as far as life
life is precious i will always vote to
protect life at the beginning of life
and at the end of life
the person who leaked this document did
it on purpose to intimidate the supreme
court remember there's no evidence of
that it is unconstitutional
it will now go back to the states and
this is a way if it's true
that the people are empowered to make
the decisions in each state
i support the overturn of roe v wade
next
wallet
next wallet issues polls show that the
most pressing issue to voters is their
wallet wages are rising but prices are
rising at a faster rate meaning that
people are losing money inflation is at
an annual rate of 7.8 percent the
highest in 40 years what specific
policies would you promote to tame
inflation you each have one minute mr
mccormick oh this should be great well
listen as someone who's actually created
jobs and which is the primary goal of
what we need to do in pennsylvania is
create jobs i know a lot about this and
this inflation is killing working
families it's killing elders tell us
what you need to do three things we need
to roll back the massive spending under
president biden it's been a huge spike
deficit is down from trump to biden of
this inflation the second thing we do is
unlock our energy industry a big part of
the inflation is the rise in the cost of
fuel and what joe biden's done is taking
us from being a net energy exporter
that's a global issue that the u.s can't
fix by itself we need to unlock that
energy that'll unlock our economy as
well and put inflation in check the
third thing we need to do is have
pro-growth economic policies make
permanent the trump tax cuts and
deregulate those are actually
deficit-positive tax cuts slovenia
that'll maintain our our young people
these people are really dumb really
really dumb
the trump tax cuts raised the deficit
biden has since reduced the deficit and
he's saying do the opposite of those
things to lower inflation administration
is passing these multi-trillion dollar
big bad bills
stuffed with green new deal
policy that's hurting our pennsylvania
farmers and our energy sector and this
inflation that biden administration has
caused is costing every pennsylvania
family more than five thousand dollars
it's a hit in their wallet of five
thousand dollars that's a lot of money
people are struggling to buy gas for
their car and get groceries they're
having to make decisions some of them
aren't even offering a single solution
and the ones that are are offering
solutions that aren't solutions sylvania
so that we're growing it's really a
turnaround we've been going in the wrong
direction for the last over 40 years
like really ask yourself after each of
them answer the question ask yourself
can i restate what it is they would do
what would they do
over 1500 miles all across the
commonwealth you mention a county to me
i see faces i see stories i remember
their stories i'm looking in their eyes
and people feel unnerved all across the
commonwealth we all know that something
has fundamentally gone wrong with how
our nation is being ran right now biden
inherited an inflation of 1.7 percent
and now is over eight percent and
climbing i just talked to a farmer not
too long ago he said is there a single
solution in here that was the question
just to fertilize 600 acres of corn
today he's probably a lot of manure here
20 000
and that is going to continue to go up
we have uh mccormick talking about
bringing energy back uh he and oz
they're both globalists and they have
very strong ties to the world economic
forum that was primarily responsible for
convincing germany to kill their own
energy independent and now they come
before us talking about how they're
going to bring energy not a single
policy proposal dr oz
there are three major ways we can
address inflation much of it caused by
overspending throwing money in
particular during covid all right had
problems and we now know that much of it
was fraudulent in the industry
but now that we've got the problem of
inflation the highest we've had in 40
years three things we can do we can
raise interest rates which is what's
being done that's what biden thinks we
should do true will ultimately result in
our collapse of our economy into a
recession collapse is too far city
issues that are driving up prices when
the pizza guy needs parmesan and
mozzarella he's got to pay more because
he can't find it
third option the best option because
it's the major driver of inflation is
energy and right beneath our feet here
in pennsylvania so the first thing was
right raising rates actually does slow
inflation but if you do it too much
you'll get unintended consequences the
rest of this is garbage we could we
could put it in the trash with his
drinkable silver that the biden
administration believes in a woke
ideology around the green new deal which
is no no why woke has nothing to do with
inflation done and then time allotted
and yet that's their narrative and
they're not going to change their minds
so we're suffering mr bartos
okay
i'm running for the united states senate
to save main street pennsylvania and the
by the administration's energy policies
which are at the root of so much of the
inflation we're seeing are an insult
to farmers working families and main
street small businesses across all 67
counties five candidates i spent the
pandemic
organizing a group to save small
businesses we raised three and a half
million dollars helped over a thousand
women and men keep the lights on keep
the dream alive owning their own small
business we have out of state political
tourists who have dropped into this
state to seek this seat to run for the
seat they don't know main street
pennsylvania and you cannot save main
street if you can't find main street but
we do know someone who can find main
street john fetterman can find it and we
know that because he spent the pandemic
bulldozing main street and he will do it
again in the united states senate this
seat is too important to send an
out-of-stater who doesn't know us to
washington i will beat john fetterman
and i will fight for main street in the
united states no answers
penn state studied aging population in
pennsylvania it's there is no substance
here no substance at the population it
is estimated that in the year 2030 20 of
the population will be over 65. mr
bartos you're a pennsylvanian who
probably wants to retire in pennsylvania
and dr oz you're a heart surgeon who has
worked with elderly patients miss
barnett your website talks about more
choices for medical care how would each
of you balance the budget both
protecting seniors you have 60 seconds
each with ms barnett tell us yes you
know we talk about balancing the budget
and yet that hasn't been done we see our
legislators going to washington dc and
simply kicking the can down the road it
is about growing our economy that is the
best thing that we can do that's the
most effective thing that we can do is
begin to if you want to shore up
safety nets such as social security to
be able to to provide for individuals we
need to begin to grow our economy and
how do we do that by stabilizing the us
dollar by by by creating an environment
where businesses do not want to leave
wasn't the question about health care
their jobs follow companies who are
willing to produce here
locate here and invest here but in the
environment in which we find ourselves
it's a very hostile environment when you
have janet yelling galloping all over
the world incoming yelling uh wealth
managers not to invest in america energy
how do you grow that economy so that is
what we need to do we need america first
senators who understand what it means to
stay to the benefit of stabilizing the
us dollar mr bartos
obamacare robbed hundreds of billions of
dollars from medicare
and make no mistake
medicare for all is on the ballot with
this seat in november
every democrat running has i wish that
were true
and they will ram through medicare for
all the democrats have said it they will
do it if they retain control of the
united states senate and they will blow
up the filibuster our senior citizens
need a trusted fighter a lifelong
pennsylvanian who knows how precious
our senior citizens are to the lifeblood
and the very fabric of main streets
across all 67 counties i'm running to
save main street pennsylvania and i'll
be fighting for our seniors and i will
make sure there will be so his solution
is to prevent medicare for all which
already doesn't exist so it can't be
responsible for the current problems
when i'm a united states senator dr oz
so i went to wharton business school to
study healthcare finance while i was in
medical school at penn
and the issue with an aging population
is you have to find ways of providing
them not just traditional medical care
but preventive services transportation
to the doctor someone to help with
groceries it's a more comprehensive need
what president trump did and it was very
wise was to build up medicare advantage
a mechanism of using the private sector
insurance companies to provide more
efficiency than medicare could provide
on its own that has allowed almost half
of the older citizens in this country to
get access to a lot more services much
more comprehensively than it could have
been otherwise offered the other thing
we have to do in pennsylvania you know
it would be funny if the boring guy ran
on i'm the only man on this stage who
won't send these types of eyebrows to
washington
positions in high schools around
pennsylvania most recently in wyoming
county where they're training young
people to work building oil pipes and
it's fantastic they can learn the
electronics they can become nurses at
the facility they can learn to drive the
trucks but these are the jobs we want
our young people to have together we'll
make it work sure for mr mccormick and
ambassador sans you both have experience
in foreign policy while the world is
watching ukraine is dr oz the guy the
bad guy from spider-man
the u.s is cautious to confront russia
because of its nuclear threat
what would you do to advise a president
of either party on dealing with threats
from any of these countries you have 60
seconds each mr mccormick first well i'm
going to have to comment on two things
kathy brought up the world economic
forum first of all i've been a
successful ceo of two companies the one
was in pittsburgh which created 600 jobs
the young people that man was talking
about the world economic forum is where
ceos gathered the last time i was there
three or four years ago it was with
president trump where i attended a
number of meetings where we talked about
the american first agenda which which i
participated in right um with regard to
the 30-day fund which jeff thank you for
what you did on the 30-day fund that's
great but i think it's important for
pennsylvanians to know during that same
time you got a ppp loan for two hundred
thousand dollars which then you
subsequently um a month later um bought
a condominium in palm beach um and so i
don't think pennsylvania main street
goes through palm beach so so i think we
should stay on the issues and the issues
here are creating an economy that's
vibrant for pennsylvania and talking
about what it takes to create policies
and bring people back in place keep
young people here in pennsylvania that
makes the future bright all right well
let me turn to the forum you were
supposed to explain how to do it um the
foreign policy my question i was i was
mentioned specifically nobody answered
the question i responded you both have
been about you both i think have made
your points i wasn't in palm beach okay
you're not somebody
okay all right
um i mean i should have a chance to
address him he called out my real estate
he called out my ppp you're good she
saved my employees
my employees by the way were in
pennsylvania in connecticut so as the us
ambassador to denmark i actually liked
the boring guy the best by far
and china while i was at post they
couldn't hear me so
let's give the mic
can we turn up my mic please is someone
yelling so they can hear me can you hear
me now
can you hear you can you hear me now
thank you let's start my time over
please
thank you so much as the u.s ambassador
to denmark greenland and the faroe
islands
i worked from 2017 until 2021
countering russia and china
we work to do things like
stop chinese-made 5g and the company
huawei from
being the the uh chosen backbone for the
danish telecom system we worked to
counter russia in the high north as well
and we did things like block that
russian gas pipeline
our adversaries are serious these are
serious times
they require a senator who's ready on
day one there's no one else on this
stage or even on either side of this
race who has actually put america first
policies in place in action doing it
they all talk about it i've done it
we know that we have nuclear powers
around the world and we have a weak
corrupt and compromised president in the
white house
we need to send strong america first
senators congressmen and in 2024 a
president because we know that peace
thank you strength works thank you and
you can do that other thing normally
website the third element of the
bathroom ms barnett
your website calls our immigration
policy chaotic and mr mccormick your
website says a country needs borders dr
oz you are the child of immigrants
everyone is watching the crisis at the
southern border but what about the other
significant immigration problems the
huge number of people who come to the us
and overstayed their visa how would you
handle this other immigration problem of
people who come to the u.s and overstay
their visas you have 60 seconds each
first to you dr oz there's no point
talking about any strategy with people
who have stuck in here as often happens
through airports and bus stations
but not through the southern border
until we deal with the southern border
because in the southern border unlike
the two other situations we're funding a
cartel
that is running a human trafficking
operation
and they have so much money that they
make running people human beings across
the border they can buy narcotics and
with those narcotics which they run with
the human beings that they're
trafficking they're able to allow
americans unknowingly to take fentanyl
and die
this past week that happened to the son
of someone that was in my audience and
he was torn apart and angry about it and
understand
there's no question if you have a
hundred thousand americans dying of
opiate overdose which will happen last
year that's four times more than died of
covet under the age of 50. we got a
problem so the border is a traffic
profit center for cartels once we deal
with that border and close that down
we'll get our arms around other forms of
illegal immigration ms barnett
[Applause]
yes before i answer your question greta
allow me to say with uh mccormick once
more that the uh that he created uh
within the world economic forum a
division for to to combat what he calls
systemic racism we also know that the
world economic forum is primarily
responsible for these esg scores uh
environmental social governance scores
that will treat us like trying to treat
their people with social credits if
you're good enough if you're compliant
enough if you're woke enough then you
may be able to go ride the train today
that is what his or he's a part of that
organization as well as mammoth oz as it
relates to immigration we not only have
legal immigration issues but we have
illegal immigration issues i think we
all know about the illegal immigration
issues so we have to secure the border
we have to do the things that we need to
do as far as uh putting and reinforcing
remain in mexico first safe asylum but
we also have a u.s
cis a uscis immigration issue as well it
is a broken um it's a broken
organization that flows up to the senate
and i will provide that jurisdiction
over them thank you miss barnett and if
you could hold your if you could hold
your applause for time purposes mr
mccormick uh you can respond for 30
seconds yeah i have no idea no no idea
what she's talking about it is awesome
we just tweeted it out a few moments go
ahead tweet tweet away i have no idea
what she's talking about i've answered
i've answered the question
and uh and in terms of the border uh
listen it's absolutely critical we
secure the border as i've said on on my
website i went to the border six weeks
ago i have the endorsement of brandon
judd who's the president of the border
patrol union and we've got to fix that
incentive problem people think they can
come across the cartels are in charge
they're exploiting it's the most
exploitive thing i've ever seen and the
fentanyl crisis is right here in
pennsylvania and it's a disaster we have
to hit that first all right you've tried
30 more seconds for the reply of 30 more
seconds on the overstaying visa thought
well listen the the most important thing
is to solve the southern border crisis
none of them is going to give you an
answer as to what to do on the overstate
visas sylvania we see it in our
sanctuary cities as part of a broader
woke movement and a liberal extreme set
of agendas which is really creating uh
they haven't had a solution for
overstate visas ever and woke is
something they've been talking about for
18 months in china it has to be shut
down it comes across the southern border
it's managed by the cartels and it's
killing pennsylvanians we have to hit
that and we have to hit that hard
for our next question we turn to kdka
radio anchor rick dayton greta thank you
this question is for miss barnett for
ambassador sands as well as for mr
bartos my wife and i have three sons all
three of them graduated from suburban
pittsburgh high schools two of them
chose to attend college here in
pennsylvania when they were done it
turns out that two of them also chose to
leave pennsylvania leaving just one here
they chose to do that because of taxes
quality of life and other opportunities
elsewhere for ms barnett ambassador
sands and mr bartos give me specifics
how do we reverse that troubling trend
so that our top talent wants to stay
here in the commonwealth and other
states that are dwindling in population
who first
miss go ahead please miss right now yes
um almost every single problem we face
in our country and pennsylvania will
certainly be a part of that is as a
direct result of 22 years of real income
stagnation for the bottom 90 in america
now how do we fix that we get better
people in office who can begin to guide
our nation in a different direction but
when people people primarily vote for
republicans because they believe once we
get in office we will actually go in and
solve the root cause of problems but
they're wrong that's that's the thing
that wrong about it like a pack of
hyenas and get nothing done for the
people then the people naturally pivot
towards democrats who won't solve your
problem but they will cut you a check
and that is how we're on this path where
we find ourselves on the road to serfdom
so we need to get america first senators
in office who will force the federal
reserve to begin to stabilize the dollar
or clarify their mandate to stabilize
the us dollars stabilizing the dollar
raises the bottom 90 income over 90 um
doubling it over uh every generation
that that's crazy that's bonkers here
all right that's a cuckoo moment
we're gonna take a quick break we're
gonna have more questions for the
candidates when we return that question
was for three of them they let one
person not give an answer and now we're
in a commercial this is uh i i i
apologize to
to dogs and for my language but
this is a dog [ __ ] debate guys this this
is the craziest thing i've ever seen
they don't even i mean
in many debates we don't get enough
substance they're not even answering
questions they're like three people get
to answer this one one person we're
going to a break now
it's it's such a such a pathetic
situation okay i want to say thank you
so many of you were signing up for
memberships during that first sec
section of the uh of the entire thing uh
let me thank the following people
because these people are so great i want
to say thank you to sue sigrist as well
as timothy avery scott greenside andrew
kinney adam gingrich cindy nelson
and others
really appreciate everybody signing up
today uh you can sign up at
joinpakman.com you can use the coupon
code obama obama and who who was it we
endorsed for that thing we've endorsed
jp right j.d mandel oh okay oh well that
welcome to anybody's welcome to be a
member whatever your name is you're
you're welcome here um and if you'd like
a free membership
you can just fill out the very short
form at davidpakman.com
free membership
thank you also to kind af a tale milo
wild texas bear claw
and uh
who else was there here manny
manny as well
really appreciate everybody should be
here with the trump rally on friday more
than likely more than likely and stick
around after the debate because we'll be
looking at my appearance on the right
wing trigonometry
for now
what we're doing is brigading their
comments let's just see a few of the
comments that you find folks have left
it looks like hundreds of them
i love how david pakman is able to
counter all questions with facts and not
opinions nicely done even misspelling my
name to make it all more more believable
this david pakman fellow makes excellent
points that's andrew kulp i recognize
that name from my audience
congratulations on getting david pakman
thank you david any opportunity to try
to talk reason into those with misguided
views using facts logic science and
empathy is worth taking
absolutely nothing but productive
conversation and discourse from pacman
what a treat to see him on the show you
guys are great pacman's babies are the
only ones i wouldn't abort i think that
that's a compliment i don't know we're
about to go there to visit them
they've been there since the 1770s and
as a matter of fact we would drive
through these thriving towns and then as
the decades went on these towns hollowed
out people moved away because companies
and jobs went offshore largely to asia
and it has caused a dearth of
opportunity for our young people
we have world-class universities in
pennsylvania
we have world-class healthcare we have
the opportunity to harvest the energy in
our ground not just to power our country
but also to make products
we have enough energy under the ground
in pennsylvania to power the entire
united states for 300 years could they
maybe spell pennsylvania correctly
that
i will be able to partner with the next
republican governor to create
opportunity and unlock the regulations
at the federal and the state level so
that our kids and our grandkids have
that opportunity that they don't have to
leave pennsylvania to find their their
future it will be here people complain
mr bartos same question please
so i want to return to something
i want to return to something that david
said before it's interesting that he
wants to talk about different real
estate and the pandemic
i was spent the entire pandemic in 2020
fighting to save main street small
businesses david was hunkered down in
aspen colorado at one of his many homes
now how did he buy all those homes he
runs an investment fund or he did until
he moved to pennsylvania a couple months
ago to run for the senate investment
funds make it on fees
our peacers pension fund
that invests money for retired teachers
and is paid in by existing teachers and
staff in schools across the commonwealth
his firm failed pennsylvania seniors
scott and i when we campaigned in 2018
we met every week seniors who were
struggling to stay in their homes
because of property taxes firms like
david's
made 600 million dollars over a decade
pennsylvania seniors didn't get what
they paid for indeed they got screwed
david and his firm got rich pennsylvania
seniors and all taxpayers got screwed
sure david thirty-second steve i grew up
in that main street place that everybody
here keeps talking about where there was
a carpet mill that was uh losing jobs so
i know exactly what people talk about
and then i went and created jobs 600
jobs here in pennsylvania i was part of
the firm i led that that was a huge part
of the success of the revitalization of
pittsburgh i'm not going to apologize
for the success i had in terms of
piecers piecers made four billion
dollars four billion dollars and this is
a story that was planted by men in the
new york times and the teachers unions
and uh here's the beauty of it folks you
can go to the piecers website and see
the facts for yourself so this is a good
example of things being completely
misleading and moments at the source of
it and jeff's carrying his water we're
gonna move on to the next question we're
gonna move on to the next question
about this you're carrying them as well
carrying members order why don't you
talk to the state reps who serve on that
board the state treasurer who serves on
that board the very people who fight
every day amendment four billion dollars
[ __ ] them sure we've got a billion
dollars short four billion billion
dollars short two percent we've got to
move on to the next question substandard
returns i kind of gotten better returns
in an s p 500 index fund paying 10 basis
points so could trump have instead of
doing his real estate in the world was
drilled in pennsylvania in 1859 mr
bartos on your website you support
american energy independence ambassador
sands you want to be the energy senator
from pennsylvania while there is a
desire for cheap oil and natural gas
there's also a concern for the
environment would you support subsidies
for green energy development ambassador
sands
you know it's a loaded question first of
all i like the 300-year on-ramp to green
energy because we know with american
innovation that our natural gas here in
pennsylvania it'll be 300 years if you
deliberately just fund fossil fuels
and national security i'm calling to go
back to energy dominance so that we have
enough
for our country we don't need to be
buying energy from places like russia
venezuela and like joe biden's radical
administration suggested iran that's
blood energy instead we can sell some of
our extra energy to our allies and
partners in europe so they don't need to
buy russian gas
we know that we have the capability to
do it here in the united states i'll
support all kinds of energy i am all
about energy because we need inexpensive
energy when you're filling your gas tank
at the gas station i want you to think
of carla sands for the senate because
i'm going to bring that price down right
you're not going to be thinking of
electric vehicles when you think about
her that's for sure
mr bartos
[Applause]
if we're to have healthy main streets
across all 67 counties the number one
thing we can do is unlock pennsylvania's
bounty of god-given energy right under
our feet we're here in western
pennsylvania you all know as you drive
around the roads here in western pa how
important energy is to everything else
we were in beaver county just last night
that cracker plan a seven billion dollar
investment right in beaver county is a
down payment on the future of
pennsylvania's not only energy industry
but industry in general we should have
five of those across the commonwealth
downstream across all 67 counties we're
seeing in luzerne county tomorrow the by
the administration can do something if
the president had the guts instead of
declaring war on energy he could combat
inflation and get our energy industry
moving again by signing some executive
orders lng should be shipped till we get
the pipelines in until we get the
processing plant there we need to ship
those on rails the president could do
that the president tomorrow could sign
uh an executive order that frees up
exploration way more than he has the
president tomorrow could loosen
regulations on permitting we need a
senator in washington fighting for our
energy here in pennsylvania kdka news
anchor rick dayton has our next question
we have danced around this a little bit
but let's drill down on it right now
pennsylvania like many states faces a
tremendous number of unfunded
liabilities things like pensions for
teachers against guarantee you get no
answer to this one for dr oz please if
elected to the u.s senate what are you
going to do in washington to help states
like ours with these significant
financial burdens
actually maybe he'll answer dr oz please
lead the way
well in this case we're talking about
fraud abuse and waste 20
of property taxes in pennsylvania are
linked to unfunded liabilities from the
pension system and i had an opportunity
to deal with it this week with several
representatives from the property tax
coalition several members of the the
representatives in harrisburg were also
involved it's stunning and i just want
to pick up on what jeff bartos was
saying earlier about david mccormick
bridgewater his company was able to to
provide services to the pension plan for
10 years dave was ceo guys i hate to
interrupt this completely meaningless
non-answer i'm starting to get a huge
dump of emails from people telling me
that a video has been released of
radical republican congressman madison
cawthorne engaged in some kind of sexual
homoerotic event with his own cousin
with his own cousin uh
we got to research that very strongly in
these kinds of extra expenses and dave
mccormick cannot serve as senator it's
disqualifying if he did that to us
before he was elected before he even
moved here he was making money office
mr mccormack
what
i think to go to piecers again again go
to the public site folks you're seeing
hearing a lot of misleading information
not a single pensioner ever lost a
dollar and what the pensioners bought
was consistent what they got was
consistent with what they asked for
which was an insurance policy so this
was they were the people of pennsylvania
and the pieces was well served what we
need in pennsylvania are pro-growth
economic policy is what we need
nationally or pro-growth economic
policies we need to lower taxes we need
a governor and a senator that actually
understand how to make the economy work
we need to unlock the energy sector
that's a combination of partnership
between the senator and the governor
because we need to streamline the
pipeline approval process we need to
have an lng port in philadelphia the
path to success is unlocking the
wonderful opportunity here in
pennsylvania you have to have somebody
who understands how to do that someone
who understands how to create jobs
someone understands how to cut through
red tape and someone who has a track
record of actually doing it which i have
the most of all of that on this stage
for our next questions
for our next questions we're going to
ask each of you a question based upon
your credentials we want to know how
your experience would lead you as u.s
senator to approach well i recommend
drinking silver yourself and anyone else
on the stage this is about what you
would do you will each have 60 seconds
question number one goes to mr bartos
you work in real estate covet has
devastated commercial real estate as a
commercial real estate lies empty it
also devastates local businesses such as
restaurants some cities may never return
to their previous occupancy rates as a
u.s senator what would you do to
revitalize the commercial real estate
industry and the businesses it supports
well as i mentioned once or twice
tonight i spent the pandemic saving
small businesses and doing my level best
to help main street stay on its feet
while john fetterman and the democrats
bulldozed it every chance they got
now if we're to have healthy main
streets
if we're to have healthy communities if
we're to have a healthy commonwealth it
starts with energy we've talked about it
a bunch tonight as a united states
senator my solemn duty to go down there
on behalf of the great commonwealth of
pennsylvania is to fight for our energy
industry to fight for our number one
industry agriculture we had two debates
last week two and a half hours not one
question about agriculture our
agriculture community is literally the
foundation of this
so he was asked about real estate and
he's complaining that last debate there
weren't questions about agriculture i'll
be a senator who not only knows and
respects our agriculture but will be a
fighter for our family farms family
farms are truly the backbone of our
communities i'll be fighting for them
every day energy is important on that i
was with down in greene county a couple
days ago passing a family farm from the
fifth to the sixth generation
it's like they don't even pretend to
answer miss barnett on your website you
speak about homeschooling your children
you have concerns with the values taught
in the local public schools not all
parents have the resources to homeschool
or send their children to private
schools as a center what would you do to
make public schools more attractive to
parents like yourself president reagan
want to abolish the u.s education
department do you agree
i do agree on abolishing the education
department i think they have served
their
moment of usefulness can you guys hear
me in the back
yeah listen um and i do understand are
they all suspicious that their mics are
too low because they keep mentioning
their mic volume but below the bottom
rung of the economic ladder i grew up in
a home with no insulation no running
water an outhouse and a back and a well
on the side but no one ever told me i
was a victim no one ever told me that
because i'm black because i'm a woman
because i'm poor all the odds are
against me and as a result i was able to
claw my way from underneath the rock to
create to create a different narrative
for me and my children along with my
husband that is the kind of america we
need an america that gives hope to those
who find themselves you think if they
asked what's your favorite food they
would even answer that with all kinds of
foolish and non-scientific mandates and
regulations and
i'm against nanny states telling us what
to eat the doctors were wrong when they
gave us the food pyramid i walk into a
room thank you doctor barnaba thank you
thank you miss barnett thank you mrs
barnett dr oz
[Applause]
doctor you are a heart surgeon you have
treated thousands of patients many drugs
and generic components come from china
for example forty percent of the u.s
supply of heparin a drug to prevent
blood clotting comes from china
importing drugs from china is less
expensive than producing them here what
would you do to make us less dependent
on china for these medicines
china is an existential threat to our
country the reason we have to fix all
the other problems we're talking about
today on our on this stage is so that we
can protect ourselves against china who
desires for us to fail and i'll tell you
why they have a surveillance state
giving rise to an economy that's viable
and we have
a capitalistic economy coming out of
democracy the world wants what we have
but only a third of the world has access
to it so if we don't take back control
of our national security from china
we're in trouble and as a physician who
went through covet and struggled with
you guys there's no question we didn't
have ppe we were intimidated by the
chinese and told that we shouldn't make
a big stink about what happened in wuhan
and where the virus came from or they'd
shut down our ppe i'm talking about
plastic masks and simple garb that we
should have already on our shores you
mentioned pharmaceuticals vital
medications we could not get access to
during the pandemic we still don't have
access to these raw materials because of
china as well as india so we must be
serious about this we have to onshore
these businesses it will also help build
viable communities here in pennsylvania
mr mccormack you worked as a deputy
national security advisor under
president george w bush many believe
that our actions in afghanistan and our
response to ukraine have telegraphed
weakness to the world one country that
is watching us is china china has made
its position on taiwan clear that it
belongs to mainland china if china
should attack taiwan would you support
sending our military to defend the
island
well as someone who's served in the
military for almost a decade fighting a
certain ideology someone who's served at
the highest levels of government
uh negotiating toe-to-toe with china
someone who's done business globally a
small part of that business in china
just like president trump that gives me
unique credentials and what is this
particular thing and uh no we wouldn't
we shouldn't tell televised what we're
going to do we should get create a lot
of lethal support for taiwan
our own strength in that part of the
world to be able to support what actions
we need to take but we need to create
uncertainty strategic uncertainty and
this is an area where i think mehmet is
absolutely compromised because
while i was serving they're all clueless
about it quite frankly was in the
turkish military and these issues of
national security are going to be on the
front on the front
porch of every u.s senator going forward
and his connection to turkey and the
fact that he couldn't get a security
clearance today is an issue that needs
to be discussed in this campaign and
it's a fair issue for him to have to
address
dr oz 30 seconds
this is a distraction there is no issue
by national security and president trump
despite david's earnest efforts to do
everything he could to earn his
endorsement was unable to succeed
instead president trump endorsed me
calling me america first he knows what
you should know which is that i love
this country there is no compromise
element here i will serve this nation as
our senator and do a wonderful job
identifying all the issues going around
the world in part because i've traveled
so much around the world the show for
example is in a hundred countries so i
just should move around and identify
opportunities ambassador sans
hey is so is the madison cawthorne video
is it technically incest i mean what i
don't even know it's such a bizarre
story guys records sometimes even our
key allies an example would be american
jamal khashoggi and saudi arabia going
forward how do we deal with saudi arabia
and its human rights record saudi well i
think the biggest issue is china of
course saudi arabia is a you know is
certainly not honoring human rights but
let's look at china where they have
almost two million people
uh held in concentration camps where
they're torturing and doing terrible
things to the uyghur people and others
including christians that's the issue
it's not saudi arabia or any of these
smaller countries china is our biggest
threat and that's why dave mccormick
could never be trusted to hold the line
on china he made his billions in china
you don't make billions in communist
china without bowing to the chinese
communist party how is he going to
investigate china's military aggression
or the fount the the virus but kathy
barnett she says that she you know she
she's this all this but as a matter of
fact she used the same playbook two
years ago and lost in a red wave year by
20 points to a weak democrat john
fetterman is not a weak democrat he's a
strong democrat and i will beat john
fetterman in november now to our
lightning i'm sorry she called my name
and she made a statement that is i know
greta i'm sorry sorry she did it someone
said people wanting to speak are really
getting in the way of greta running the
debate 2020 having won 76 percent of all
of my precincts and then over the next
three days because of
unconstitutional male imbalance i ended
up losing i i thought you said
unconstitutional melon those particular
precincts not only did i uh
have that um that thing happened to me
but president trump she said i lost by
20 president trump lost by more than 26
percent to an equally weak democrat joe
biden
thank you i had that thing happen to me
now to our lightning round you have 30
seconds
should we demand china pay reparations
for covet mr mccormick yes we should
demand that china pay reparations for
covert we lost a million americans and
trillions of dollars of value and we
should also have reparations for
fentanyl because the fentanyl is being
manufactured in china that needs to be
stopped and and my credentials on on
fighting china are without question i
have spoken about china 15 years ago
about the risk of china and i'm taking a
lot of heat on china here mammoth again
this is a perfect example of the
phoniness
if you go to his financial disclosure
members against chinese food he won't go
near it from a deal with usana mr
mccormick thank you sleep.com and the
chinese communist propaganda ambassador
sands the same question
absolutely but as a matter of fact
memorized when the pandemic hit said we
have to follow the chinese communist
party example and the chinese communist
party is in control of the who they're
corrupt and they instituted lockdowns as
we know they're still locking their
people down we have to say never again
will we free people be locked down or
accept mandates we are citizens of the
united states and we have our
constitutional rights of course we
should ask china not ask we should sue
in the world court and get
reparations dr oz both candidates
both candidates mentioned your name you
have 30 seconds to respond to everybody
you know china has continually cheated
at everything they embed faculty in our
universities they're able to bribe some
of our companies that they are able to
gain access to our media they play with
our tech companies uh and we have not
been serious about the threat they offer
there is no question they owe us
reparations i'd start with the one
actually i'll just start with the debt
that we have to them and then the
account imbalance they refuse so if i'm
totally serious if i had to if one if i
got to choose and it was one of these
five people who had to be the next
senator i'd probably go with bartos
china money is not good or bad but how
you acquire it is up for discussion and
when you're taught when we were locked
down in 2020 uh all in this together
mammoth odds was inking a deal with a
manufacturer in china called doctora
sleep.com made in china so now he wants
to talk tough and bring those jobs back
but when he had the opportunity to find
manufacturing here in america he went
over there mccormick uh he is you cannot
be embarrassed with china financially
and not also ideologically is the
republican party greg i don't think i
got that i don't think i got one on that
no you can you'll get a lightning rod
question okay you promised yeah promise
is the republican party big tent enough
for representatives marjorie taylor
green and liz cheney ms barnett i'll
give you that one first liz cheney no um
but if we can make room for aoc clearly
we can make room for marjorie green mr
mccormick listen i go across the
commonwealth pennsylvania i don't see a
huge fragmentation in our party i see
pennsylvanians and pennsylvania
republicans and conservatives coming
together around an america first agenda
they believe there's room for aeoc in
the gop
and they're terrified of the prospect of
uh of john fetterman joe biden has
brought the conservative party together
the republican party together and i
think our party is is going to win in
2022 because of that dr oz
the only thing joe biden has built back
better is the republican party the
question was about liz cheney over time
to give us a reason to unite
but we keep showing up at cultural war
knife fights with neatly arranged three
by five index cards
we have to get into these issues the
liberals are taking over our media they
control much of government the corporate
suites are dominated by the woke
ideology in our universities as well
we've got to engage at all levels we'll
need different kinds of people to access
these different books
i've been working for almost two decades
to support our party around the
commonwealth
now for those of you watching at home
these two guys have spent almost 60
million dollars fighting with each other
first of all by the way i think you
should get your money back because 40 of
the electorate is still undecided but
they've spent all this money fighting
with each other and my entire campaign
has been about bringing the party
together to fight for the people of
pennsylvania our farmers our energy
industry pennsylvania families and main
streets of course across all 67 counties
that's how we win in november we cannot
trust this seat the two people who
parachuted here thank you they're
spending all that money fighting with
each other mr mccormick and dr oz you
have put out negative ads against each
other do they violate reagan's 11th
commandment do not speak ill of another
republican mr mccormick well um
first i had ads attacking me before i
even announced i was running for office
but by mr oz it was it was a good
welcome to politics and uh the ads that
have been run against uh mehmet these
guys
uh wonderfully in mem its own words so
if you call that a negative ad i don't
think so i think that's a presentation
of a set of positions that are
completely incongruent with republican
voters listen he um he's got he's a
hollywood liberal that has had held a
set of positions that he has
flip-flopped on every single one and
just like trump is america foreign
standing on president trump's shoulders
because he can't defend dr oz
desperate dave dishonest again
once again
president trump endorsed me because he
knew that these ads were as vicious
towards me and untrue as they were
against him because they're delivered by
insiders who are scared of what we
represent which is telling the truth and
pushing back hard i will do that for the
very reason president trump endorsed me
and just y'all know before i even knew i
was in the race because i hadn't entered
yet i was being attacked by david
mccormick so it goes both ways
thank you
ambassador sands
ambassador sands when you were
ambassador to denmark what an
informative debate greenland from
denmark what did you think about that he
was the third u.s president to make that
suggestion and i thought it was an
awesome idea because he's a deal guy and
we know denmark can't afford to develop
or defend greenland but as a matter of
fact i just want to refer you to the men
on the each side of me they have both
flip-flopped and we know we want to send
an america first senator to washington
not a squish because we know that's how
we're losing our country to the radical
left because the democrat party of today
is not the democrat party of our
childhood it's not the party of jfk
thank you very much aoc and bernie
sanders and they're miss radical
socialists miss barnett you are
miss barnett you are an african-american
conservative woman 87 of america of
african-american women vote democrat
what is your outreach to them yes it is
true i'm black
and i've been black all my life
fact check it
listen
black people are not special little
unicorns we want what everyone else
wants we want good schools we want safe
streets we want good jobs we don't want
liquor stores on every street corner the
problem is in the republican party for
good or bad we have the best story to
tell the problem is we keep picking
people who suck at telling it thank you
miss barack now it's time
now it's time for our candidates to give
closing remarks
we just have one minute we start with mr
mcgregor we've learned nothing i'm sorry
closing remarks one minute please i'm
running to save america uh the america i
love from slipping away the weak
policies and the wokeness of joe biden
is killing our our economy inflation our
energy sector it's poisoning our kids
with fentanyl and it's putting america
at risk i grew up in bloomsburg
pennsylvania playing uh sports wrestling
and football and shikolimi and shikshini
and selinsgrove i went to west point i
served in the 82nd i went to iraq and
then i had a great successful business
career
everything you need to know about me
happened in those first 28 years
the
judeo-christian values and the
pennsylvania values i learned in
bloomsburg from my parents
the duty honor country i learned at west
point the exceptional america that i saw
firsthand in the 82nd airborne division
i'm a i'm a battle tested pennsylvania
true i've been america first my entire
life i know how to lead i know how to
fight i know how to win and it would be
a great honor and privilege to go fight
on behalf of all of us in washington as
the senator from pennsylvania miss
barnett you're closing argument closing
statement
i am you pennsylvania
and like you i believe this is the
greatest country that has ever existed
but like you i believe our country is in
trouble i believe that the america that
allowed me to claw my way out of dire
poverty is about to come to a close
listen this time you do not have to hold
your nose and vote for the lesser of two
evils
i am in a statistical tie for first
place so voting for me is not throwing
your vote away well she's down like five
isn't she kathy barnett for senate and
you will see exactly what i'm doing
today that i will amp up tomorrow after
this race i have been going in you will
see me at rooms full of black people
changing their voter registration from
democrat to republican you will see me
downtown in chinatown they are mine you
will see people ushering me in front of
a room full of amish people with them
introducing me as someone with their
values not only does it look
but i can go into every nook and cranny
and take the votes that we need in order
to really beat betterment in the general
election so let's go do this
mr bartos you've been shortchanged a
little on the time or give you a minute
30 but for from the 30 would you answer
what you're going to do about the polls
between now and may 17th in your closing
statement about the polls about the
polls having you what are you going to
do to get your numbers in the election
polls and not the polish people are
helping the ukrainians right i just want
to vote
okay
um honestly they're not treating this
guy very well i'm not gonna lie
i'm a proud son of writing pennsylvania
and my hometown of redding is hurting
and dozens of towns and cities across
pennsylvania are hurting just like
reading because for too long
career politicians in washington simply
didn't care
about main street pennsylvania
this campaign has never been about me
we in pennsylvania have been polluted
with 60 plus million dollars of
advertising to get to a place where 40
percent of our electorate and maybe more
are undecided ask yourself why because
the people of pennsylvania are smart
they're smart enough to not buy the
nonsense they see on tv and they're
smart enough to know that john fetterman
knows this state
they know that he knows the state
because he spent did he genuinely think
he was being asked what are you going to
do about polish people cannot trust this
seat to out-of-staters who moved here a
mere months ago
i humbly ask for your vote on may 17th
i'd be honored to serve this great
commonwealth and all of you i will go to
washington and fight for you and your
families you can trust me to do that
it's what i've spent my career doing
i didn't just move here for an
opportunity i will go to washington and
fight for our conservative pennsylvania
values god bless you thank you so much
for being here this evening
may 17th jeff barthouz for united states
senate ambassador sanders your one
minute closing yes first of all of
everyone on this stage i have the
highest proportion of african-american
support because
african-american families
are they want opportunity for their kids
and grandkids and that's what i offer
you know
i'm carla sanz and i'm running for the
united states senate
and i need your help
i have a website carla sands.com please
sign up and volunteer and help our
campaign i'm humbly asking for your vote
on may 17th
i want to make a pledge to you i pledge
that i will be a faith-filled person in
the senate
representing you i pledge that i'll take
my business experience
my foreign policy experience trade
policy and defense policy experience to
the senate and i will fight for your
pennsylvania values every day and i will
put america first every single day i
want to thank you
i want to just let you know that i
appreciate every one of you who will
vote for me on may 17th and i will not
let you down dr oz she seems super
confused
i've been pushing back against
uh orthodoxy my entire career i
developed the devices we fix heart
valves with without having to open the
chest
on television i took on big pharma when
i thought they weren't doing the right
thing took on big agrichemical companies
when they were developing pesticides it
could be dangerous i took on big tech
for a lot of reasons years before the
rest of the world woke up to what they
were doing and i took on the us
government i fought in the big stage
network television i know how to do it
i've got the scars to prove it i cannot
be bought
now having done all that
i have the wisdom and what it takes to
have a bold loud voice in washington the
reason president trump endorsed me and
he gave a lot was that he knew i would
win in november he felt that was the
most capable of doing what we have to do
as a party carry populations that have
forgotten about us they haven't heard
our wisdom i am confident that if i am
honored with your votes i will do
exactly what he promised i would do
which is to be smart tough and never let
you down
we've come to the end of tonight's
debate
thank you to all the candidates for
their time thank you to the audience for
their respectful participation and a big
thank you to grove city college for the
incredible support hosting tonight's
event good night
uh the worst debate that i've ever seen
for sure i mean uh i don't know it's uh
yeah
yeah it really is that type of a
situation just absolutely and completely
horrifying and maybe trump will be able
to figure out who he endorsed we've
endorsed jp right jd mandel okay let's
get now to my interview with the right
wing trigger nomitry let's pick it up
oh i don't know we did democrat we did
buy an administration
um
okay yeah let's pick it up where we were
and uh listen operations could have gone
better is that do you think that's good
hold on
when trump was given trump
that that was a quagmire
no listen i mean i think we were
identify anything that changed
materially is that
um i i what i would say is i think some
progress was made in a very difficult
situation i don't claim that the
situation became
dramatically different and we are now
like way way towards a solution and also
i think i'd also consider that it's not
an issue i know enough about to have a
proper discussion with you as well
that's fair let's let's we'll we can
table it on that on that basis
um no listen i mean as far as joe biden
joe biden's not exciting to me you know
i'm a progressive social democrat so joe
biden's not exciting he did some good
things so he did a third covet stimulus
at a time that i think it was necessary
extended a pause on student loans got a
pretty good infrastructure bill passed
got us out of afghanistan which i think
was a great thing i think that that was
a quagmire
but be oh yeah oh my god i mean
i agree with you with a quagmire point
but did you feel that the way that was
done went well
i think it went as well as it would have
gone no matter who did it
wow
interesting i mean when asked trump was
asked what would you have done
differently
and he literally couldn't articulate a
single difference so at least
trump was going to do it and he another
failed promise
biden did it and when trump was given
the opportunity to articulate how he
would have handled it differently
he couldn't name a single difference so
let me in the most factual way possible
i've not heard
trump explain what would have gone
differently and therefore i have no
basis on which to assume it would have
is that fair
i suppose it is
the question for me is i i
i mean
i struggle to imagine it going any worse
so
i kind of feel like there is a
possibility that the preparations could
have gone better is that do you think
that's unfair i have a struggle to
imagine it could have gone better so
like i think where i land is it went the
way i expected you know and and it was
correct ultimately to get out okay
please carry on answer up to you
um
bye we're talking about whether you're
happy with the biden president yeah i
mean it's like listen um
he's doing exactly what i expected you
know i didn't expect him to do anything
on cannabis decriminalization and he's
not and i didn't expect any at least in
the first two years immigration reform
and we're not getting it so you know my
i try not to become jaded or cynical but
basically i've seen from biden exactly
what i expected okay
you mentioned trump being a humiliation
and look uh uh you know neither francis
or i were pro-trump um i thought
i thought he raised some important
issues by the way uh you know and
immigration not not not being least of
those we can have a conversation about
that maybe later on but um if if trump
was a humiliation perhaps in the way
that he talked and you you mentioned
some of the promises that he didn't
deliver on the optics of the biden
precedent presidency do they do they not
make you cringe somewhat when he's
shaking hands in mid-air with people who
aren't there and forgetting things and
all that
beautiful so are you guys open to a good
faith conversation about that absolutely
absolutely okay so let's go piece by
piece
um does joe biden sometimes lose his
train of thought absolutely
absolutely there's no question about it
and he's close to 80 years old if you
compare joe biden today to joe biden
when he ran circles around paul ryan in
2012 it's not the same guy i have no
problem saying that that's absolutely
the case
no argument whatsoever
the shaking hands with midair video was
a total joke and i'll tell you the story
about it the weekend that that story you
know the shaking hands with midair
i looked at the clip on my phone and it
was a very short clip where you just see
biden stop speaking he turns to the side
and he goes like this
i said oh my goodness this is it this is
terrible biden he seems worse than trump
when trump came off of his plane
and his car was right in front of him
and trump wandered off and was brought
back by the arm by a secret service
agent and they said here's your car that
lit that's worse than when trump had
rudy giuliani sitting right across the
table and said
where where's rudy said maybe i'll ask
rudy to say a few words
you
thank you very very much mr president
first of all congratulations on
what is in fact a historic uh start of
an administration i've never seen so
much done
in some short a period
hey you know what good for them for
putting the clips in though right i mean
like good for them for putting the crips
clips in we have to give them credit for
that this but that biden clip looked
that
um and i was gonna report like guys this
something seems wrong with joe biden and
then i found like the actual full
frame instead of the square twitter
video
and you could see what happened after
and joe biden had people to his right
and to his back right and to his back
and and he literally finished the speech
and turned and said something to the
people to the right and then he turns
back and he does the exact same thing
and then to the other side and does the
exact same thing so
that was
a non-story for me it was a completeness
yeah david
i haven't done enough research and i'll
admit it readily that i don't know
whether that's accurate but i'm happy
for the purpose of this discussion to
accept that fair but would you accept
that joe biden
mentally is not at his peak i think you
already have i already have yeah
so
is is that not a humiliation
well when i say a humiliation i go by
what is global opinion of the united
states
that's my because i'm one guy right and
so yeah what what is so i want to say
what does the world think
and we know because of global gallup
studies and global pew studies and
others
that opinion of the united states as an
as a country
of the us's ability to lead
of the president of the united states it
was in the toilet to use a phrase trump
likes you know to flush 10 or 15 times
opinion was in the toilet under trump
and it is recovered dramatically under
biden so i try to take myself out of it
and just say what does the world think
and there's a couple of exceptions
russia liked trump better than biden
again this is not
rhetorical it's just the opinion polls
russia did like trump better than biden
i think turkey liked trump better than
biden
and for some this may be wrong but i
think i have nigeria in my mind liked
trump better than biden but other than
that
empirically
our global reputation has recovered
dramatically under biden so that's my
standard that i use
hey constantin do you like show now
we're going to an ad
uh let's see how it all continued
uh i guess it's the next section
and do you not think that
the problem
with trump trump was never the problem
he was a symptom of the problem
which is a large part of the working
classes and the ross belt in particular
felt alienated by the democrats they
felt they weren't being represented by
them
and that's why they voted which shows
that there is a real problem
amongst that part of the left that they
can't connect with the working classes
because the working class if you're just
joining us this is an interview on the
right-wing channel
trigonometry and it's getting flooded
with comments antagonizing me
so we've been brigading the video and
leaving like comically positive comments
feel that they have their best interests
at heart
so i would say a couple different things
i would say there is absolutely a
problem with the democratic party that
it is not
doing enough for the working class i
again i'm not a democrat i don't care
about the party i gladly concede that
what i see as the problem with trump
is more
i agree with the idea that trump was a
symptom rather than the problem
but for me the problem was if trump
doesn't have people who fall for his
obviously false promises and complete
lack of understanding of any issue
if people don't fall for that trump's
the crazy guy yelling in the new york
subway right the danger comes from the
fact that in the united states there are
so many people who are either
here they go like are you suggesting
that a lot of trump followers are stupid
and i'm like yeah that's it's they were
like
not engaged with politics at all that
when a celebrity pops up they go that
sounds kind of good i know who trump is
or they're so
um they lack knowledge of issues to such
a degree
that when they hear trump say i'm gonna
fix trade
by putting tariffs on china
and nobody trump doesn't even understand
that it's american companies that pay
the tariffs and all trump starts saying
look at how much we charge china and
then his followers go we charge china so
much and it's like guys
it's the american companies that pay the
tariffs so when people don't understand
stuff they fall for people like trump
and that to me is the problem because
without the cult members you don't
become a cult leader you need followers
to be a cult leader and so i agree with
you that trump is emblematic
as a symptom rather than actually being
the problem but my perspective is a
little bit different as to why
david can i uh in the spirit of a very
this is the best good faith but honest
conversation please can i feed back to
you what it sounds like you just said
from where i'm sitting yes which is
francis was saying to you there's a
large portion of the american public who
are so alienated by some of the rhetoric
on the left that they they went
to they had to resort to voting for
donald trump that's his argument and
what you said is no that isn't really
the problem the problem is americans are
ill-educated and quite stupid and full
for for trump's bombastic statements
that's what it sounds like did i hear
you right it's a combination of both
okay now here's one thing about it
sorry david just to finish this point
isn't that always the case though i mean
it's not like the public got massively
more stupid and ill-educated in the last
four years right or the last six years
so well
i don't know
i don't know about that i mean i don't
know how much you follow american
education
but i think
let me put it this way it's beyond me
to
deeply dive into that specific niche of
this discussion but i think there are
many who would make the case
that actually
the american public on average
has become less educated over time
okay
let's i'm using the term educated
because technically more and more people
are getting degrees but i think what i
meant to say was just more ignorant
thank you
but wouldn't wouldn't you accept that
these movements these right-wing
populist movements we also had this here
in the uk with brexit and uh it's an
issue that probably you i i don't want
to assume but you may know less about it
than we do and certainly we would say in
this country that
the same arguments were made these are
stupid racists whatever people but
actually if you speak to a lot of people
who voted this way which we didn't
neither of us did but if you speak to
those people their concerns
uh were not based around ill education
or whatever but it was uh there were
some issues that they were raising that
were not being reflected in the public
debate that were dismissed and
certainly from our perspective it seemed
like there were some parallels with the
united states so it's not that people
got more stupid or less educated it's
more that their concerns were being more
and more ignored by the left-wing
parties and they were desperate for some
kind of way out which is why they voted
for brexit and which is why they voted
for trump that's absolutely valid and i
have no qualms with that that's what
took place i think the reason i'm has
skeptical to accept that the reason for
trump was
that democrats have abandoned the middle
class
is that more democrats crossed party
lines to vote for john mccain in 2008
than the number that crossed party lines
to vote for trump in 2016. and so
i hesitate to say that that was the
particular reason because the numbers
don't bear it out no i believe it okay
sorry to interrupt but the thing is you
said yourself what trump did and what
brexit did is it brought a lot of
non-voters out of the shadows if you
like so exactly so what actually
happened is these people who stopped
voting for the democrats and for labor
years and years ago because they felt
like these parties stopped representing
them we have a labor party here in the
uk that stopped representing working
people they would argue a long long time
ago and finally a movement came along
that actually represented them so it's
not the mccain democrats we're talking
about here we're talking about people
who are non-voters for decades perhaps
who are now back in the fold because
they're finally seeing someone represent
their views that's the argument
so
that's an empirical question which i
don't have the data in front of me to
say i've not seen any data that suggests
that
20 years inactive democrats are who came
out to vote for trump
it's like a super specific claim we just
neither one of us really had the backing
to say that it's you're making that
assertion i can't deny that that
happened i've just seen no evidence and
unfortunately without the data it's hard
to engage with it any further
okay so that's fair enough
to david what do you think as a as a
person or as on the left when it comes
to globalization
because in many ways you could argue
that globalization is a positive you
know we get things goods cheaper etc etc
but also i get the sense that whenever
one of the guys is doing the asking the
other seems kind of like annoyed that
they're even talking to me oh
it means that we don't produce enough at
home we've lost our manufacturing bases
you know and that means that you then
have towns which become disenfranchised
because they have no factories
manufacturing etc etc and then creates
the types of areas that will vote for a
right-wing populist such as trump
yeah i'm i i
am basically with you 95 of with what
you just said the last piece and it
logically leads to people voting for
trump let's put that aside for for now
at least and maybe we can come back to
that so my view on globalization is as
follows you know generally speaking uh i
am in favor of specialization you know
at a basic economics macroeconomic level
i understand the reason why we would uh
have circumstances where
one country doesn't just produce
everything you know we there's trade i
believe trade is a net positive i
believe specialization is a net positive
i think the problem i have with a lot of
the conversation about domestic versus
um
import when it comes to a number of
different product services industries
is that there's a sort of naivete where
both republicans and democrats in the
united states love to say we're going to
bring it back home it's going to be made
in the usa we're going to bring it here
we're going to be independent this type
of thing
and the the truth is that
through cumulative economic policy
decisions over 30 or even 40 years
dating back to you know ronald reagan
the united states has
chosen and i mean chosen again not one
one person didn't decide this but the
cumulative effect of decisions has been
we would rather
get stuff from other countries and be
able to buy it for less in the united
states rather than
manufacturing here and maybe this would
create some jobs but everything would be
a lot more money so i often say you know
cheap tchotchkes from china are a really
important thing in the american economy
and so when trump would say we're going
to make it all domestically or when
biden says we're gonna make it all
domestically number one these are like
multi-decade projects to to change
supply chains on a lot of these things
and there's not sort of like a just
upfront thing where like everything's
gonna cost more
and most americans don't want that
because you know half of americans can't
afford an unexpected 400 expense all
right so i don't know that we're going
to watch the whole thing let's go to um
we get into the trans stuff which is
kind of interesting let's let's see
can i can i it's a dick move to ask you
this but can i ask you to define a woman
is that okay yeah so listen i mean i did
a whole thing with this right-wing guy
named michael knowles a little while ago
okay you know we were talking about the
definition of a woman and the context
was
um the katanji brown jackson hearings
and her refusal to answer and there i
argued that makes perfect sense because
they're asking in a legal context the
question is who can bring a
discrimination lawsuit on the basis of
gender and i thought she was right not
to answer it and i made the point that
depending on where you're asking the
question the answer could actually be
different now i'm glad to give my view
of this socially if that's okay sure
yeah okay so this is again and the
problem with this and i know you guys
would never do this because you seem so
honest the problem is that sometimes
this question is then used to put
someone in a corner so i will say in
advance that the definition i have will
not work in every setting okay like for
example the definition i have in an ob
gyn's office may not work because we
recognize biological differences right
but for me
the broadest way where i think about
who am i going to relate to as a woman
it would be somebody
who i identify
as
deliberately
trying to exist in the world as a woman
and so okay if i see a biological man
who
and again we we have to talk about this
in candid ways which some people might
not like but i think it's necessary if i
see if if i see me
with a wig on
it's not going to be
apparent to me that that's someone who
is necessarily trying to exist in the
world as a woman if they go by the name
david and their their voices like mine
and they dress like me so i'm just going
to make the best faith effort i can
where if it's if it's indicated through
a number of different cues that someone
is trying to exist in the world as a
woman i'll relate to them as a woman
that's fine it just doesn't bother me oh
sure and in fact i am kind of where you
are in the sense that we've had a [ __ ]
ton of trans people on the show and we
call them by whatever name they have and
the pronouns that they they've chosen
right i've got no issue with that
however
my issue is that in
and again this is being straight with
you i hope you don't take offense to
what i'm saying please in your in your
refusal to to give a definition that is
equally applicable in different
circumstances you're kind of avoiding
the difficult elements of this right
well the difficult elements are the
exactly that which if okay i'm sorry i
interrupted
let me i know you know where i'm going
but let me just give the example so
people know what we're talking about so
we have a a number of cases here in the
uk for example and i know you've had
some in the us as well where a trans
woman who still has a male anatomy has
been housed in a female prison and has
gone on to commit sexual assault against
women in prison right okay we obviously
have had uh trans women in male sport in
female sports where they in my opinion
have an unfair advantage uh and there
are other situations in which our
failure to give a clear like universal
definition means that women in
particular in this very instance are
suffering the consequences of our social
unwillingness to be quite hard-lined
about it would you agree with that well
there's that's that's what in in a in a
court they would say that that's a
compound question and we've really got
to break down each of those because
whether i agree with everything you said
i don't know
so let's let's i'm not even sure where
to start so um okay i mean in prison
there was a sexual assault by a
biological male housed with women okay i
i don't know the story
we have a country of 331 million in the
united states so you can find examples
sort of of everything um
sexual assault by biological females of
other females in american prisons is
really common so for me what i go to is
less about
you know trans people i think are
one-third of one percent of the
population in the us i i may be slightly
off about that but
let's use that as a working number
for me every assault is bad
and the bigger issue is american prisons
are terrible at keeping inmates safe and
i apply that to men's prisons and
women's prisons
but you're deflecting here aren't you i
don't well but no i don't think so but
let me let me go first let me give you
the reverse of your argument right now
but well
it wasn't even shooting black people is
is bad but the real problem is something
else and we shouldn't talk about the
cops see i didn't handle this correctly
i should have said the problem is those
aren't the same because my solution
solves the problem you're talking about
right if we solve violence in prison we
solve the problem that they're talking
about whereas the deflection he uses as
an example and i didn't realize it in
the moment
solving as he says black people if if we
solve cops shooting black people that
doesn't have anything to do with his
issue of black people shooting black
people so it was actually a terrible
analogy and it got it he it got over my
head at the time shooting black people
no no that's not the argument i'm making
okay sure go ahead sorry so the the
point that i'm making is but no because
th that what you're saying is it's i
guess it depends on what you say the
other issue really is that you didn't
get to the end of that and so
that's the right wing argument black on
black crime is the real thing forget
about cub shooting black people right
but those are totally different things
what i'm saying is
violence in prison is a major okay so i
kind of did make i didn't make the point
as well as i would have liked to problem
and i don't deny that an added layer of
complexity is yeah in which prison
should
a trans person be i don't pretend to
have the answer in all cases i don't
pretend to have the answer i'm conceding
it's very complicated
is it complicated if you have a penis
should you be in a female prison
well but not everybody who's a trans
woman has a penis but these people did
and they were in female prisons both in
your country in an hour i i just don't
know the case i don't know i don't know
the answer
should a person with a penis though be
in a in a female prison it's it's i
would have to know more about how these
decisions are being made i i don't know
enough about how the decisions are made
to be able to say
so i mean listen let me put it let me
put it a different way let me put it a
different way
and i i don't know if anecdotes were
we're both being so anecdotal that i
don't know if this is even useful but
there are there are many instances
where i could show you
a picture of someone and describe their
height and weight to you
and
it would be very hard to argue that they
should be
in a men's prison for their own safety
i'm not arguing for that
we've had trans people on the show who
say we need to make provisions so that
trans people uh are in a separate
facility where they're going to be safe
from males who otherwise would
potentially be a danger to them right so
translation is a third prison for trans
people that's what some people have
argued on our shows i'm not saying you
take someone who identifies as a trans
woman and you stick them with men
because i don't think it would end well
for them so i don't lack compassion what
i'm trying to get out with you is do you
envisage circumstances under which it is
right to put a person with a penis in a
female prison
uh i can i can envisage uh theoretical
circumstances where it's the best of the
options that are available yeah i mean
right now there are no third prisons for
trans people and so if you say to me
what is more like i mean like listen
let's just be very upfront if you have
if you have a trans woman that is
biologically male and has a penis but is
slight in size and has a very feminine
appearance
by all
statistical likelihood they are far less
likely to assault someone in a women's
prison than they are to be assaulted in
a men's prison and so that's a
particular case where i would say it
makes sense for them to be in a women's
prison yes
okay
we could go we could go around for hours
but
all of a sudden we've spent too much
time on this guys before we move on in
the situation i outlined do you concede
that it makes more sense for them to be
in the if the only two options are a
men's or women's prison
would a 5-3 biological male with a penis
who is outwardly feminine and and is
seen by the average person as a woman
you're not going to put them in the
men's prison are you i think it'd be
very dangerous to do so fair so we agree
on that that's fair all of a sudden he's
saying yeah in the two choices we have
all of a sudden the penis should go in
the women's prison wow well well we
don't agree on that because i don't
think either of those options is except
he wants a third option but that wasn't
the issue at hand
we should look for a solution rather
than going i would love another solution
but it seems like we want to be given
the two current options we are on the
same page
uh
no i i just think both of those options
are completely unacceptable to me and i
think we need a third solution and
that's why i feel strongly about it do
you see what i'm saying i see what
you're saying i i but it sounds like
before you realized it might not look
great to concede it that you agreed in
the two options we have now the female
prison makes more sense
uh i think this is where i'm gonna do it
david pakman and go i think it depends
on the individual circumstances
if this person is in prison because of
sexual assault against women
i i don't know that that is the right
choice personally okay i mean maybe in
that case they would be we're now
getting so in the weeds but yeah that's
the case that's why they might be they
might be in solitary confinement anyway
in that situation as i said i mean we
now we're really getting too narrow i
think sure yeah
hey kkk all right so anyway that's as
far as we're gonna go with it today but
it was it was fun to do and they i guess
they don't want me posting the entire
thing on my channel which is funny
because it would probably get hundreds
of thousands of views on my channel but
they seem to kind of be against it i i
would love to do it um i let's look at
some of the comments you guys have left
here
um david pakman is authentically these
comments are so positive from you guys
that to us they're to our community
they're obviously a joke
david pakman is authentically concerned
about the truth and the welfare of all
and i can can't think of two things more
worthy of prioritization the way he
carefully unpacks arguments is beautiful
and so appreciated
uh let's see
david was spot on wow
um but there's still a lot of negative
stuff you know their audience does not
like me i'm not a good faith debater
david you pair it big tech big media
david is such a well-spoken guy thanks
for bringing him on it gets a bit boring
to hear you guys talk out of your asses
that's pretty good
oh look look at this weird there were
literally no positive comments about
pacman and then loads appear out of
nowhere all gushing about how great he
is reminds me of uh wait do i have it
here
oh no i don't know if i have it
it's a fraud exactly
they call them dumps yep
uh so they seem to be figuring out
what's going on
you guys have to do better research when
dealing with very slippery
and fact orientated characters like
pacman that's genius look at that
you have it it's it's a it's an insult
but it's praise you have to do better
research when dealing with very slippery
and fact orientated which by the way i
think they mean fact oriented characters
like pacman
yeah
david parkman did an amazing job
bringing fact and level-headedness
all the misspelled praise is also
interesting pacman is like a real-time
fact checker have him on more often
pacman is as is and as studious
knowledgeable and articulate and just as
we could have wanted
anyway so i think i think the comment
bombs have probably uh been been noticed
at this point in time
thank you to robin your rhubarb for the
twitch prime subscription i want to say
thanks to jan martin majes
matthew rumor
and troll man peralta for the three
gifted subscriptions those with peace
and love i am now gifting to
the following people
joan dean
alyssa ducar
and ernie kovach
thank you so much and i really
appreciate everybody's support
that is going to do it for me today we
did the debate we did the trigonometry
and uh
i'll see everybody very soon what else
is there to say
are we off
we're off right
congratulations sir you just won the
election oh okay now we're off